international vous interveniez depuis
moscou où maurice leroy ancien député
français directeur général adjoint du
grand moscou nous a rejoint maurice
leroy merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors l'ambassadeur de
france en russie sera la seule présence
officielle française aujourd'hui on l'a
dit 1 ce matin 1 pourquoi selon vous
ont écouté interrogé l'ambassadeur de
france je suis pas le porte-parole d'
emmanuel macron il ya d'ailleurs
quelqu'un d'assez controversé pour ça
interrogé l'ambassadeur de france je
sais que le président est le même à
qu'on devait venir effectivement
normalement le 9 mai au défilé le jour
de la victoire c'était important
l'ambassadeur de france représentait
aujourd'hui notre pays la france et bien
sûr le président de la république les
autorités françaises au défilé donc la
france était représentée par son
ambassadeur ce qui est légitime c'est le
rôle d'un ambassadeur je suis d'ailleurs
entretenu avec pierre lévy il y à
quelques instants seulement alors
maurice leroy effectivement vous êtes
également vous à moscou peut-être a
manqué ce que vous retenez de ces
célébrations de ce matin et notamment du
discours de vladimir poutine
écoutez d'abord c'était une première
pour moi d'être invité par mon ami marc
accos new line qui était le vice maire
de moscou jusqu'il ya peu en charge du
grand moscou nous sommes connus dans les
échanges grand paris grand moscou avec
le maire sergueï sobianine
et maintenant vous savez que marc accos
new line et vice premier ministre avec
un portefeuille important
je traduis pour nos amis français c'est
équivalent un ministère d'état en france
et donc j'ai eu cette chance de pouvoir
être invité et d'être à la place rouge
très impressionnant très émouvant aussi
parce que on voit les vétérans ceux
encore qui ont les derniers qui ont
participé au second conflit mondial
ensuite du discours du président
vladimir poutine je retiens les choses
très important il a rappelé à juste
titre que les peuples de l'urss puisque
ça s'appelait comme ça à cette époque de
l'urss ont payé un lourd tribut un lourd
tribut il faut le rappeler toujours 27
millions de tous les peuples russe qui
sont morts dans ce conflit l'urss a payé
lourdement
la victoire sur le nazisme il faut
jamais l'oublier c'est important de le
rappeler
on le sait en france comme ailleurs il y
a des révisionnistes hélas de l'histoire
russe a laissé ses thèses affreuse qui
disent que à auschwitz ou du crevale on
aurait gaz et que des poux quelle
horreur donc c'est important de se
souvenir c'est important de commémorer
donc ce 75e anniversaire reportée à
cause du coc vide
la date d'aujourd'hui n'est pas n'est
pas neutre j'ai demandé parce que je ne
savais pas je me suis interrogé donc on
met au mexique le 24 juin s'était
effectivement le jour en 1945 du défilé
présidé par le grand maréchal joukov
et donc c'est une date aussi historique
même si elle n'a pas pu se faire
le 9 mai que je retiens un autre élément
très important du discours du président
poutine s'était à la conclusion il a
appelé les nations à être des forces de
paix et je pense que c'est un message
très
important un message de paix dans le
monde
de rapprochement entre les nations en
faveur de la paix je crois que c'est
très important a souligné
je m'en félicite effectivement on a des
propos qui avaient qui sont également
tenus dans une lettre du président
vladimir poutine qui a été publié dans
une revue américaine la semaine dernière
là encore on en a parlé
vous en tant que directeur général
adjoint du grand moscou comment est ce
que vous percevez plus précisément les
relations franco russes aujourd'hui et à
l'avenir qu'est ce que vous voyez on
sent que ça capote un petit peu parfois
et puis ils sont aussi des
rapprochements notamment depuis la venue
du président russe en france rencontre
emmanuel macron souvient fort de
brégançon
écoutez on sent très nettement
je suis ici à moscou depuis un an et
demi vous avez eu la gentillesse de
rappeler que j'étais député vice prise
en assemblée nationale quand j'ai quitté
mon mandat pour venir ici travailler au
grand moscou avec mara de pouce new line
et sergueï sobianine le maire de moscou
qui est d'ailleurs un joue un rôle très
important à la demande du président
poutine contre la pandémie du
coronavirus ici à moscou et s'est sauvé
line a fait un travail colossal et est
reconnue ici pas seulement à moscou mais
mais dans toute la russie
écoutez je sens vrai réchauffement des
relations franco-russes jeu j'en parle
avec l'ambassadeur pierre lévy
évidemment nous services de l'ambassade
avec emmanuel quidet le président de la
chambre de commerce franco france russie
d'ailleurs ma note id la chambre de
commerce qui a fait un travail
formidable durant toute cette pandémie
pour tous nos chefs d'entreprise nos
entrepreneurs faut que nos compatriotes
français sachent que la france par ces
entreprises est le premier employeur
étranger
le premier employeur étranger à moscou
et en russie donc c'est très important
notre présence et nos échanges ici voilà
et donc moi je je ressent réellement et
sincèrement des relations plus resserré
plus plus chaleureuses et on sent bien
que le président emmanuel macron a donné
depuis le fort de brégançon une
inflexion est une orientation très clair
de rapprochement j'échange aussi avec le
président nicolas sarkozy qui vous le
savez un ami de la russie et nicolas
sarkozy pour elle vous dira aussi que on
sent qu'il y as eu ce rapprochement
c'est très important on savait parce que
en vérité ça a été dit tout à l'heure la
javel oreillettes donc j'entendais votre
débat par le précédent interlocuteur
l'embargo disons le clairement appelons
un chat un chat est d'une stupidité sans
nom
parce qu'en fait c'est la france qui est
pénalisé je fais une confidence au camp
jean yves le drian est venu je lui ai
dit tu sais jean yves personne te le
dira peut-être dans les services mais au
forum économique de saint-pétersbourg
l'année dernière sais-tu quelle était la
délégation la plus importante après la
chine eh bien c'était la délégation
américaine vous entendez bien je répète
volontairement la délégation américaine
était plus importante en nombre après la
chine
voyez faites ce que je dis pas ce que je
fais c'est classique ce donc
l'embargo est une stupidité dans
l'agroalimentaire les fruits et légumes
aujourd'hui vous trouvez des camemberts
produits par nos amis russes
alors je veux pas me faire tirer les
oreilles par mon ami et camarade hervé
morin le président de la région
normandie évidemment ils n'ont pas la
qualité et la saveur de nos bon
camembert normand et autres il y en a
d'ailleurs aussi dans la région le
centre val de loire
mais voilà donc les russes ont produit
les produits et quand il les produisent
pas les achète à la chine
donc c'est très malin on a perdu des
marchés je ne rencontre pas un chef
d'entreprise français ici et il y en a
croyez moi qu'il me dise que l'embargo
est une stupidité et d'ailleurs ils
l'ont dit lorsque bruno le maire est
venu ici pour présider le forum
économique franco russe il y a quelques
mois nous avons eu un échange et que le
ministre bruno le maire et tous les
dirigeants d'entreprises l'ont dit et
pas seulement des grandes faut penser
aux très petites entreprises il y en a
aux moyennes entreprises etc
donc c'est important la présence
française
au plan économique ici donc on a besoin
de ce réchauffement
moi je suis optimiste je pense que
évidemment c'est une décision européenne
elle n'appartient pas qu'à la france je
suis certain que le le président
emmanuel macron agit au niveau de
l'europe avec nos partenaires
madame merkel l'allemagne la pologne
évidemment qui joue un rôle majeur dans
cette question de rapprochement pour
faire en sorte que on aille vers une
levée de l'embargo kymera non une
stupide je le répète
merci beaucoup merci vous disant maurice
leroy
c'est la france un dernier mot on doit
on va avancer
merci infiniment maurice leroy d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien député français
directeur général adjoint du grand
moscou et cette histoire à présent celle